da schwingt ein vorwurf mitkommen madsen
nicht mehr raus zum autogramme geben
nach ihren konzerten das und mehr jetzt
im community video also es geht heiß her
die fans fragen und madsen antwortet
essential amino acid fragt wieso habt
ihr nicht als alices gern weitergemacht
schöne insider frage auch weiß weiß kaum
noch jemand dass wir mal eine band die
alles kann hieß und ich habe da englisch
gesungen und damit kann man die frage
beantworten
ich kann das nicht so gut ich kann
besser deutsch texten und irgendwie war
es so dass madsen aus einer band
entstanden ist die wiederum hörsturz
hieß und es war sozusagen deutsche
crossover vielleicht kennst du dir auch
noch und mittlerweile ist es aber so
dass wir eigentlich madsen so geändert
haben das ist eigentlich fast ein
bisschen klingt wie alles kann früher
nur dass ich halt deut länger und
irgendwie ist ganz viel von der von der
alten band dann doch bei madsen mit drin
würde ich sagen
paul heckmann möchte wissen wie kam es
zur zusammenarbeit mit kalle com und kiz
kfz unfall so finden wir spitze und egon
haben aufgenommen in einem studio in
bochum im kanal 22 dort haben wir auch
aufgenommen
dort gab es ein toningenieur schönen
gruß an ecke und ecki hat uns empfohlen
für dieses feature die dachten irgendwie
madsen wäre vielleicht doch ein bisschen
zu poppig und zusagt dann haben sie aber
ein paar songs von uns gehört die auch
anders können und dann war den jungs
klar den wollen wir haben den schreihals
und dann habe ich total gerne gemacht
komisch oder depots möchte wissen was
ist der grund für ihren erfolg und warum
kommt er nie raus zum unterschreiben
das stimmt nicht wir kommen sehr gerne
und oft raus zum unterschreiben bei mir
ist es jetzt gerade so dass ich wir sind
auch am anfang der tour ich bin noch ein
bisschen vorsichtig aber die anderen
jungs sind eigentlich bei jedem konzert
rausgegangen oder ja ich war bei jedem
konzert unten und nico und johannes und
lisa auch und lücke bei einem glaube ich
nicht aber nun sind wir da sind wir da
sehr sehr brav ist wenn wenn so ein
bisschen die krankheit umgeht will so
ein bisschen die angst ist da ist wie
krank zu werden oder wenn man so ein
bisschen schwächelt dann muss man auf
sie aufpassen dann geht das halt mal
nicht dann dann du das auch leid aber in
der regel machen wir das eigentlich
immer und sebastian die andere frage
warum sind wir so erfolgreich
ich glaube das sind wir weil wir es
nicht um jeden preis sein wollen
natürlich haben wir überhaupt kein
problem mit erfolg aber wir wollen es
eigentlich nie erzwingen und deswegen
kommt auch so ein album zustande wie wo
es beginnt und wir haben die geheimwaffe
in die kommode oder einfach unheimlich
unheimlich unheimlich gut aussieht das
stimmt das album ghosts beginnt es
nämlich antizyklisch zu dem was gerade
alles draußen so veröffentlicht wird
dass es der einzige
nach einem 90 er jahre platte so und man
muss antizyklisch denken glaube ich auch
marokko und hat zwei fragen und zwar wie
oft hört ihr eure eigene musik und was
bedeutet euch das lied du schreibst
geschichte die warmer kuchen unsere
musik höre ich eigentlich nur noch zur
tour vorbereitung ansonsten spielt sehr
oft genug und ich genieße die zeit aber
sehr der die stücke geschrieben werden
und da ich so einen song wenn er gerade
frisch aufgenommen wurde auch gerne mal
50 mal am abend und freu mich drüber und
dann aber wenn es veröffentlicht ist
eigentlich weg oder wie es bei dir
nein ich doch ich wüsste ich höre es
eigentlich war das gern
ich höre gerne im auto deine kinder ganz
gerne im auto das auch aber ich höre ich
höre gerne mit find ich stolz die dafür
sind sie noch zu jung aber aber die sind
gerne mit ok du schreibst geschichte
bedeutet mir unfassbar viel
eigentlich der wichtigste song von uns
würde ich sagen weil er uns wahnsinnig
viele türen geöffnet hat und wenn wir
den live spielen und die leute den
erfolgen bezirk ried jedes mal gänsehaut
meine frage an madsen hallo jungs ihr
habt jetzt hinbekommen dass dieses album
von anfang bis ende einfach nur genial
ist jedes lied anders jedes lied genial
jedes glied einfach nur 100 prozent
wachsen das feature mit lisa who
wirklich der hammer ich hoffe dass ihr
mir die frage beantworten können und
dass ihr mir diese cd gleich auch noch
signiert
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag
bestand und chips ja morelli vielen dank
für die blumen erstmal wie kriegt man
sowas hin das ist das passiert gott sei
dank einfacher darauf können wir uns
irgendwie dann doch verlassen dass das
ist spielfreude das ist das was wir
beruflich machen wir machen es gerne wir
lieben unseren job ist unsere
leidenschaft und die texte schreibt das
leben die musik kommt aus dem bauch
wir haben glaube ich wieder sehr viel
musik gehört die uns inspiriert hat als
wir so 15 16 waren sehr viel 90er jahre
zeigt
wir waren ariza foo fighters hell mit
alles fast kracht rage against the
machine wir haben wieder lust aber
rocken gehabt so zu sagen hast du
irgendwas hinzuzufügen
ja das dann duett mit lisa lisa ist ja
unsere live keyboarderin seit das
gründungsmitglied foley ausgestiegen ist
und da haben wir wirklich einfach ein
riesen glücksgriff gemacht mit der dame
weil die live wirklich sehr sehr schön
orgel spielt und sehr viel aus sinkt und
das duett ist er auf platte schon gut
aber live ist finde ich es persönlich
noch etwas besser und auch gegen werten
kritisch gefragt in community video
nämlich ob sie sich gerne mit den böhsen
onkelz verglichen sehen oder so was
ähnliches sind und gute ideen profi
gamer er spricht im community video
darüber ob er gerne oder ungerne der
underdog in der electronic sports league
ist das also und jeweils auch viel mehr
in den community videos mit dem 3
er sagt